what is the summer good for a
relationship or a fling with you oh
sorry volunteer um how old are you how
old are you know how it plays the part
is the general question because the
agent matters I think you know depends
let's say high school age um
I think whatever you know uh that's a
good question actually you know H thing
though no do you know what I mean yeah
yeah I'm a relationship person so I like
the idea of a relationship me too
relationship that's got together let's
go to the beach I think Lane just sounds
very shallow and like you don't really
care I think it could be a nice
relationship that you know is you're not
gonna be with this person forever but
but you kind of established that I don't
know st. fling just sounds like negative
I don't really care it's just yeah
sometimes I want to bring the fling
around my friends sometime I really care
about that's all I have lost complete
control over this
what do you could you guys relate to cuz
you were all actors in your high school
years right I wasn't so could you relate
to this whole graduating from high
school and the last summer kind of
concept absolutely yeah yeah I grew up
in a pretty small town you know so
everyone knew each other and when it was
like the last day of school right before
summer it was it was a trippy feeling
you know some people you weren't gonna
see you again or some people you're
gonna see for like the rest of your
lives and yeah I could totally relate to
these characters absolutely I can
actually relate to my character my
character Aaron spends her last summer
in an internship and I started working
my last summer so I graduated high
school and I started working on my first
TV show like right
so it's kind of thrown into that work
world which I love and I thrive from
from so I can definitely relate to that
well I was after elementary school are
pretty much kind of dived into my career
real really really early I started out
doing music and then you know eventually
went into more and more feeling but so
like the idea of the last summer not
really sitting heard like being in the
classroom setting and having like you
know high school friends that I grew up
with it wasn't really my life so it was
kind of cool to be able to do that in a
film and experience that on set and just
like she was like it's kind of get an
idea of what that was like that was cool
so I grew up in New York City and but a
senior of high school in Los Angeles so
right after I graduated high school I
had about a week or so before I was
gonna go to drama school in London and
all my old buddies and my cousin from
New York have been traveling around
doing this euro trip so for about five
days these kids I've known something
like 5 years old like we went to like
five different cities in five days but
they just wanted to go like out all
night and I never came through cities so
I didn't sleep for like five days
straight we'd be out all night and then
I'd stay up and like go to the museums
during the day so that was good how I
spent my summer nice that sounds fun yes
Tyler you I mean was putting on the Cubs
uniform something that was kind of a
dream oh that was so cool I loved it I
mean you know I feel like if you're not
a huge fan of baseball it's still kind
of like a dream come true my pops and my
brother are huge baseball fans and grew
up playing baseball and so I was always
around it I wasn't the biggest fan of it
but I loved like being down in the
dugout and like I would like go to the
bathroom and look at myself it was
really really really cool and then like
you know we choreographed the play and
the book fly ball goes over my head I'm
like my butt hit your thigh really hard
at one oh yeah yeah no she took one for
the team
thank you yeah no you you black he was
as gentle as possible when you're
throwing your scope over I tried to make
myself really light
they don't work that well it was okay
thank you some romantic gestures like
what's the most romantic gesture you've
ever done hmm um big cat Jesus I don't
know care for somebody who very deeply I
guess I when I was like 9 I
I sent a you know that you could burn
the old DVDs right and so I did a lip
sync of love songs and sent it to a lady
appear so I got lips that's what I like
that's money I've never done I should do
that well I mean um I think for me I did
like flowers you know flowers is always
I think girls love flowers so girls with
my flowers you know and they're just
like little things open the door for
stuff like that you know gentleman
gentleman splitter Southern gentleman
yeah
you